russell la commission von der leyen est
en train de prendre ses marques
elle est installée depuis une semaine
depuis le 1er décembre dernier et
pendant qu edouard philippe présentera
enfin les choix du gouvernement pour la
réforme des retraites
pour ceux-là von der leyen dévoilera le
plan de bruxelles pour relever le défi
climatique et on vous pose à cette
occasion une question sur le site du
figaro faut-il instaurer une taxe
carbone aux frontières de l'union
européenne parce que eh bien c'est l'une
des mesures phares de la commission du
plan que compte présenter ours ou
lavender le délit n le green deal
voici les précisions d'ailleurs du
commissaire français thierry breton on
va pas mettre le green deal en place en
un mois vous l'imaginez bien jeu on
parle d'une ambition sur les 30 ans qui
viennent
au cours de ce mandat de cette
commission c'est un des cinq ans on va
mettre évidemment progressivement tout
ce qu'il faut en place et compris bien
entendu les financements il ya déjà été
annoncées 1 1 font deux de transition
pour pour aider les régions qui sont les
plus en difficulté via notamment la mise
en place de mécanismes d'ajustement de
carbone aux frontières pour précisément
faire en sorte qu'il ya une équipe entre
ceux qui n'auront pas adopté ce green
deal et puis et puis nous européens
alors cette taxe l'éventualité de cette
taxe aux frontières fait déjà réagir et
en particulier réagir les chinois il ya
une autre inflexion d'ailleurs c'est
cette petite déclaration de margaret
vesta guerre qui a défendu avec beaucoup
d'orthodoxie la concurrence et dans sa
pureté cristalline la commissaire
danoise est bien celle qui avait là même
qui avait refusé l'alliance alstom
siemens vient de déclarer le temps est
venu d'actualiser les règles de la
concurrence dans l'union européenne
autrement dit permettre des alliances
européennes
objectivement denis olivennes cesser une
inflexion majeure que nous dit
la commission de bruxelles c'est vive le
protectionnisme je crois pas d'abord
d'abord l'airé de la concurrence si
décrié le fonctionnement et concurrence
européenne n'est pas si négatif que ça
devant iliad au dessus il ya deux choses
il ya la partie en titres cet anti
concentration qui ne pose pas de
problème majeur
et puis à la partie contrôle des
rapprochements d'entreprises c'est ça
c'est là dessus qu'on a le plus de
sujets mais quand on regarde
statistiquement je crois qu'il ya 3 % si
je prends tout il ya trois pour cent des
opérations qui ont été refusées
c'est très peu en vérité ces nombreux
arguments de margairaz de l'estac
oui alors alors donc que qu'on tienne
compte du marché mondial par exemple au
numérique ça paraît légitime mais ça va
être
c'est rien à côté du vrai sujet me
semble-t-il par rapport à aux conditions
de la concurrence internationale que
sont deux choses à notre politique
commerciale et c'est vrai qu'on a du mal
à santos c'est plus facile de faire des
déclarations sur l'appétit de la
concurrence que deux d'avancé sur le
plan de notre réciprocité en matière
commerciale et l'action des très faibles
et puis 2 2 il ya un autre sujet c'est
qu'on a en termes de r&d
on est très très très loin en europe des
chinois ou des états unis
donc qu'on compte qu'on aménage un peu
la peau était la concurrence pourquoi
pas je vous rappelle quand même que
celle appelée de la concurrence qui
améliore le point d'achat des citoyens
européens donc qui génère de la
croissance par ailleurs et qui pousse à
l'innovation
en revanche il faudrait qu'on avance
davantage alors peut-être que la la la
la la la jla green taxes
va dans ce sens encore que là aussi ça
me paraît un peu surprenant puisque
rappelons nous qu on à la seule bonne
idée cette grinta c'est qu'on va enfin
aider des pays qui sont des fortes
émetteurs de co2 à ceux dé carbonée ce
qu aujourd'hui l'essentiel des efforts
de des carbones 2d cabotage c'est
l'europe et l'essentiel de la production
du co2 c'est en dehors de l'europe donc
je note denis olivennes que vous ne
croyait pas à une mais en tout cas une
inflexion européenne sur ce que je pense
ça va être l'un des procès d'intention
par exemple la seule politique efficace
quand on voit google
quelle est la seule instance dans sur le
continent européen qui a vraiment
attaqué google pour l'empêcher d'abuser
de sa position dominante
c'est la commission et justement c'est
du fait des taxes qu'ils ont été
c'est la suite logique des taxes contre
contre google en tous les cas dans la
réflexion ce qui est présenté dans la
dans cette volonté de remettre en cause
justement là le dogme un peu de la règle
de la concurrence vous partager le point
de vue de denis olivennes sur cette
question journal je n'ai pas la
compétence et nie l'information lille
degré d'information mais sans connaître
le fond du dossier
est ce que je sais simplement ses deux
petits prisme qui est le mien c'est à
dire celui de d'opinion eh bien vous
avez une opinion très réceptive à ce
genre de choses il ya bien sûr le thème
de comment il ya du protectionnisme est
un terme qui a beaucoup cru ces
dernières années et a minima pour un
protectionnisme européen assez là où ça
commence à prendre une réalité parce que
sinon à la demande est directement une
protectionnisme au niveau national ça
c'est un thème qui n'existait quasiment
pas il ya dix quinze ans arnaud
montebourg avait su leur fair et
d'ailleurs et il s'est effectivement
beaucoup répandu donc là s'il voulait
c'est en tout cas en terme de geste
politique à l'égard des européens
c'est probablement une mesure
intelligente de la part de la commission
sur le fond je me prononce actuellement
visible n'est pas les chambres et de
sites non certainement l'idée du de la
protection ça moi je suis tout à fait
d'accord cette représentation la enfin
voilà on joue d'après exemple ceci étant
je ne le trouve pas très pas très
rationnel c'est cette idée parce que si
effectivement on importe des produits
qui sont extrêmement carbonée bon on va
sans doute les taxes et si j'ai bien
compris et c'est ça bon et puis nous on
va exporter des produits qui vont être
peut-être moins carboné on peut sans
doute faire ça mais les autres à
l'extérieur ils vont sans doute nous
taxer aussi parce que il n'y a pas
tellement de raison qui vous renvoie pas
la balle d'une certaine façon bon pour
moi si vous voulez cette situation là
c'est vraiment un problème à l'échelle
planétaire mais qui peut pas se régler à
l'échelle de l'europe
c'est comme quand on avait dit que le
nuage de tchernobyl s'était arrêté à la
frontière bon j'exagère un peu mais bon
y'a un peu ça parce que on est quand
même sans arrêt avec des échanges très
très important donc cette idée qu'on va
se protéger nous vous êtes contre l'idée
mais vous êtes contre l'idée d'un
protectionnisme mais est ce que vous
voyez dans ces inflexions tous les cas
bah oui visiblement en train de rentrer
une nouvelle commission
photo ben oui des cieux d'accord au
moins sur quoique malgré tout les
élections ça sert à quelque chose où on
peut dire que la peur et parfois bonne
conscience en tout cas elle est
conseillère en politique c'est quand les
peuples distincts montée des populismes
après des années design qui disent la
même chose et on voit quoi un la montée
des poppys 2 la montée du vote vert
aussi des écologistes mais y'a manche en
tirer des leçons et là on voit une
nouvelle équipe qui sait après des
années d ela ne pas tirer de leçon et se
prendra clés sur la clé et c'est là de
se dire peut-être qu'il va falloir un
petit peu de tenir compte de ce que 19
pts elle le fait sur la question du
protectionnisme connaît du
protectionnisme économique de 2,2 de
champions européens etc
c'est quand même malgré tout une
évolution par rapport à la thèse la
concurrence pure et parfaite dans
l'intérêt du consommateur
l'idée qu'il faille faire des champions
européens et pas très élégant la
concurrence à l'échelle mondiale six
pattes de recréer de la confiance à
l'échelle européenne c'est une vraie
modification taxer aux frontières des
produits alors on en est là c'est parce
qu'ils sont carbonées puis demain ça
peut être pour autre chose c'est quand
même l'idée de se dire on veut pas
laisser à la presse se protéger quand
elle lui faut remettre à plat la
politique d'immigration salue pas tomber
de la tête comme ça c'est aussi le
résultat des élections
donc c'est qu'à un moment il faut alors
est-ce que ça marchera parce que ça
marchera pas est ce que les électeurs se
reconnaissant voit ce qu'ils ne seront
pas est-ce que ça les encouragements à
voter à nouveau pour les partis
traditionnels ou contre l'iran parce
qu'on avait raison on va continuer de
voter pour les partis populistes
parce que comme ça au moins ça les fait
bouger ça je ne sais pas le résultat
mais ce qui me paraît clair c'est qu'il
ya un lien entre les résultats des
élections là en l'occurrence et
uncharted le niveau du discours de la
commission bondonny là le verdict est
clair vous êtes minoritaires sur votre
interprétation donne non seulement
j'assume
main mais non je crois que le terme est
ce que la taxe carbone aura un effet
significatif sur les changements
climatiques ayant nommé hier midi
requêtes chaque n'aura pas le thé le
thème le terme qu'il paraît inadapté
c'est le terme de protectionnisme parce
qu'on s'est globalement je vais très
vite la mondialisation a produit suffit
de regarder les statistiques de
l'économie et de la prospérité mondiale
et la santé mondiale et la natalité
mondiale a produit des effets bénéfiques
mais mais elle a évidemment un choc
elle produit des chocs de transition en
particulier pour les pays riches et donc
si vous ne l'assumé pas la
transformation que cette mondialisation
implique
vous êtes l'association crise mais c'est
le débat sur les réseaux fixes ne sais
pas
attendez attendez la réaction la
réaction la réaction qui consiste à dire
on va la créaction qui consiste à dire
comment réagir 1 on ne touche à rien on
ne fait pas la réforme des retraites
2 on se protège on sait où elle nous
conduit historiquement elle nous conduit
pas ce qu'elle entraîne
la réaction inverse l'autre côté et on
voit qu aux etats unis
on voit qu'en chine ce mouvement se
dessine il va affecter durablement la
croissance mondiale donc notre
prospérité en revanche le thème qui me
paraît légitime celle sur lequel
l'europe a été faible c'est le thème de
la réciprocité
nous ne pouvons pas être les seuls à
démanteler des barrières à l'entrée si
les autres ne le font pas c'est pas le
protectionnisme c'est au contraire le
développement du libre échange celle
inverse du protectionnisme et ça c'est
un facteur de prospérité équilibré alors
c'est la question que vous posez sur le
site qu'on vous pose sur le site de
filleau du figaro pour continuer à y
répondre vous favorable à l'instauration
d'une taxe carbone aux frontières de
l'union européenne
et pour l'instant cette rencontre
effectivement plutôt une approbation
vous n'êtes pas nombreux à voter parce
qu'il peut continuer quant à voter on va
s'intéresser 1
au dernier sujet qui tient à coeur c'est
paru dans le journal pour lequel j'ai
l'honneur de travailler les amateurs je
me trouverai pas de contradiction les
appelle les amateurs de vins sont ils
trop culpabiliser c'est la question
qu'on vous pose également sur twitter